Hey guys, it's Justine
And I'm so excited because today I'm going to be unboxing for you the brand new MacBook Pro 15 inch and the Blackmagic Design
EGPU you first things first. Let's unbox the MacBook Pro then we'll get to this guy and if you do get this be very careful
Because the handle is not a functioning handle at all. I've already learned the hard way
So this is be completely expect out 15-inch MacBook Pro and you guys might be like Justine
You're absolutely crazy. And I'm not gonna deny that fact at all my entire job revolves around making videos
So the faster that I can make those videos the more videos that I can make or I could just hire an editor
But I actually really enjoy editing. So Apple announced two new refreshes to the MacBook Pro with touch bar
There's 15 inch and a 13 inch
so the top of the line 15 inch MacBook Pro is a 6 core I 9 a
4.8 egga, hertz 32 gigabytes of ram and a 4 terabyte solid-state drive
The top-of-the-line 13-inch is a 4 core 2.7 gigahertz
I7 eight gigs of ram and you can get up to a 2 terabyte solid-state drive
So this really is a huge upgrade from the previous versions
I mean basically the MacBook Pro that I have right now is a completely spectat one from late 2016
So this one is pretty much double what I have previously I at most of my videos on the go I would say probably
I mean it's over 50% of the videos I edit when I'm traveling and before I got the 18 core
I'm a pro I edited 100% of my videos on a laptop
It really is hard when I'm traveling going back to editing on the laptop
But will the introduction of this laptop with 32 gigs of ram and a 6 core processor and the 4 terabyte solid-state drive
which is an
extremely expensive
Edition when I say extremely expensive like you could buy an entirely other
Computer for the amount that you would pay for the 4 terabyte solid-state drive
so if you are looking to save money that is one easy place to save on I mean, I think it was like
$3,200 extra for the 4 terabyte drive. I
Know well, let's open it up. This is purely an unboxing video because it's actually pretty late right now it is. Oh, it's 10
P.m. Way past my bedtime. And in a later video. I will give you guys a comparison between this and my previous MacBook
It's completely unnecessary to cut the Box open like this. I'm well aware
one of the things that was hoping is they would make the computer look a little bit different sort of like when they launched the
New Apple watch they put a little red dot on it
Not that I was looking for a red dot or anything. My sister also ordered one
And she was debating on whether to go with the silver as opposed to the space for a spoiler alert
She got the space gray as well. It just looks too good. Not to let's do this
It's always so exciting every single time
There's not much of a smell
Okay, there we go, oh, yeah, that's what I was looking for
I'm shook
This looks so clean you guys wouldn't you see the comparison of my laptop and compared to this one?
It looks like it's been through an actual war. Oh, it's already turning on I was ready
Also in the box
we've got
USB see we've got some
Paperwork and of course the power charging brick now not only do the new MacBooks get a spec jump
But they also got a new display these now have a true tone display which means as the light shifts and changes
Your screen will also change color. So it'll become warmer or cooler depending upon the light situation now for me
I do a lot of video stuff a lot of graphics a lot of color work
I'm probably not gonna have that turned on because the last thing that I want is my colors to shift as I'm working on a
Project. I do have it turned off my phone - I'm not a huge fan of it
But I feel like depending upon the type of work that you do on your computer. It's something that can be super helpful
So these MacBook Pros also have the t2 chip which first debuted me iMac pros and that will allow for a secure boot
Encrypted storage, and also let's not forget
Siri oh shoot. No
Oh
No, no, no
No
You got to be very careful when you say the HU y si RI
In my household if you guys are looking to upgrade and you are looking to save money
I think the biggest thing that you can do is not upgrade it to the four terabyte drive
I would
recommend getting the two terabyte if you are doing a lot of heavy data stuff because my sister did get the one terabyte and she
Said that she is running out of space so many times when she's editing videos
But I do most of my editing actually off of these drives. These are the Samsung. These are the t3 versions
I also have the t5 which is a little bit faster than these because I do travel a lot and I'm editing from my laptop
To my iMac pro all of my current projects that I'm working on I edit from here
I also like to have a backup off-site
just in case I happen to lose one of these and as I say that I know that there are some things on here that
They don't have backed up so I should probably put these down
There something bad happens. Another thing that is new is this keyboard? It's not entirely redesigned
I'm not really sure what they did to make it quieter, but it is much quieter
Okay, so now let's do a sound test of the two keyboards, this is my old Mac, this is the new Mac
I'm going to type Justine was here over and over again
It's definitely quieter feels like slightly springier and just like a little bit softer
I'm not sure if it's the sound that's throwing me off. Let's try again
I'm also a pretty aggressive type or so. When I type I'm pushing very hard on the keys
I'm the worst person to room with in a hotel ever
So, aesthetically these computers look almost identical except this one is dirty and scratched
so now
It's time for this
This isn't a GPU if you've never seen one of these before it's ok. I don't really get it
I've been very well aware of these because I have been wanting to try them out for a really long time
Especially because I do a lot of stuff on my laptop. Basically what this is is it's an external graphics processing unit
So what that means is you can get the quality of a desktop computer in a laptop
So this essentially is just a graphic card that helps accelerate the graphics inside of your laptop
It says that this can speed up the graphics on the new 15-inch MacBook at two point eight times
So I will be testing this out in a future video, but this is just an unboxing and a little setup of the MacBook
So stay tuned for that. Ok, so here it is. So what makes this different than a lot of other GPUs?
I've been checking out the razor one and I was thinking of getting it just to review and test it out
This is sort of Apple's answer to a well. It's not even that complex
But for most people who just want plug-and-play, that's what this is. Most other GPUs are upgradable
This one is not you can add multiple
Cards whereas this is just it's a very Apple solution you plug it in and it should work
So this has four USB ports two Thunderbolt and also an HDMI out
This is one of the first a GPUs to support a thunderbolt display. So that's pretty awesome
You can also charge your macbook through here
basically, if you want the power of the desktop in your laptop, this is the way to go this is
$699
So the do have an eye Pro this probably isn't something that I'll be using that often when I am at home
This is something that you would be getting if your laptop was your primary computer
Whereas this actually you can use it for the iMac Pro. So that'll be interesting to see if that
Makes any difference. This is really big
It's super aggressive. I mean, I guess it looks cool
it is a very
Consumer friendly way to turn this Mac into a processing power Beast a lot of other EGP use are massive
They're loud. So I'm gonna be interested to see what this thing
Sounds like I know a lot of you guys are probably super hardcore PC
people and you're probably laughing at this but to that I say not everyone is like you you will say but
These Gray's watch pretty well
This has four USB ports and two thunderbolts and an HDMI
You can connect various accessories here with the USB ports
You've ever done any sort of VR stuff on your Mac or if you have an HTC vive I've used that before when I'm editing
360 content so that will allow you to see the 360 stuff that you're editing in actual 360 when you're moving around
I'm very excited to try this out
I've always been fascinated by these and I have not ever had a chance to check them out
So now I have a really good reason to try this out and one of the razor ones which I have been eyeing up for
Quite a while ever since they announced support for e GPU. So I was like mmm, that's something I want to get into it
Well, thank you guys so much for watching. I hope you guys enjoyed this video. This just was a quick little unboxing
I'm gonna start shooting and working on my review video
I kinda will be doing a comparison between just sort of my everyday workflow of editing videos between this macbook my other back book and
my imac pro
So just to give you guys a little comparison and a speed test to see how much time I will save if you guys are
New to my channel make sure you guys hit subscribe and hit the bell. So you'll be notified when I post a new video
I have a lot of fun stuff coming up, so I don't want you to miss it
Be sure to leave me some comments as well because I will be scrolling through there and replying to you guys
I would love to know what you guys think of the new GPU and the new MacBooks
Well, see you guys in my next video. Bye time to edit Oh
Oh, I'm gonna edit this on minut
No, I'm and it doesn't my macro because the I micro is still faster than this and I don't have anything downloaded yet
So that's tomorrow's task